there you go guys amazing all right wow
it's got a kick okay here we go you know
what he's talking about
Mom let's go
this is really spicy
oh my
God
[Music]
take one hopefully there's one take only
we'll see it's okay it's okay Bill
you're so nice Okay which camera am I
looking at this one hey guys welcome to
heat eaters in this episode we're
exploring the spice of the Rich and
diverse Caribbean diaspora we're here in
little Caribbean this is home to one of
the largest Caribbean American latinx
communities outside the West Indies
literally when you're walking down the
street you can smell the smoke from all
the spices the barbecue you hear the
music playing it's such a fun
neighborhood you feel like you're being
transported straight to the Caribbean in
this episode we're going to explore all
different types of Caribbean Spice from
spicy jerk chicken to Trinidadian home
style dishes Beijing snacks and pepper
sauce I'm joined with my friends Justine
Skye Chef P from ghetto Gastro and Andre
Springer creator of shaquanda's hot
sauce I need some spicy food in my life
let's get to it
[Music]
up see that's the spot you know it's got
your chicken when they're smoking it
straight on the street oh my God it
smells so good hello smells so good
ah
yeah yeah
I can't wait are you the chef yes sir
chef and owner Nikki Nikki nice to see
you Spanish Town Jamaican style this
right here
48 Hours okay and what's what's in the
seasoning listen that's the secret trade
secret only five seasons are you really
only five you got some like real spicy
stuff in there listen man it's spicy
enough for the kids but I mostly keep
the spice in the sauce babies gotta eat
it on the side so I want you and you can
put the Escalade sauce on it very good
that's the onions and the carrots and
the Scots bunny we don't make it too
fancy we do it as if we were back home
grilled fresh raw chicken seasoned
marinated ready to go on that's really
important because if you pre-grill it
you have a chance of like drying out
yeah yeah I don't think it changes it I
don't do that yes made with love
thanks for meeting me of course of
course I would never pass up an
opportunity to have some Jamaican food
grew up eating a bunch of jerks being in
Jamaica my family's from West Bay
Portland so and I haven't had some
really yummy Jamaican food in a while
I'm so happy to be here right now well
we're here and there's a bee
so you go back to Jamaica often yeah
your music and your style is very
inspired by your culture right yeah
everything that I do in just like my
taste and and my sound sometimes even
the way that I dress but then also like
I'm from Brooklyn New York and there's a
huge huge Caribbean culture here there
you go guys
amazing all right so right now we got
the sweet chicken sauce and we got the
jerk sauce do you have any Festival yeah
come on man it's like a sweet bread
exactly oh yeah that's the best about
right there
yes and
the onions and everything she know the
sauce
yeah because this shoe like if things
get too spicy you just need some
it's a little sweet exactly crunchy
exactly so normally like on the street
like in Jamaica like what they would do
no matter like what time of night it is
on the street someone's cooking jerk
chicken get the chicken you get some
Festival you get sauces and then boom I
want to try like one of your juice like
your fresh juice it's about salt do you
like spicy and my Ginger but you already
know sorrow sorry no you got to try to
sell it it's like hibiscus I think
there's some other spices in there too
as well you know it and sometimes
they'll put like
beautiful or like alcohol yeah
white chairs is it delicious
this is like
beautiful you guys
need to be drinking this right now
another yummy thing that I like to drink
and I haven't had it in a while but uh
the Jamaican carrot juice it is creamy
and like just delicious so it helps like
Mass the the spice break it down for me
what makes good jerk chicken good jerk
chicken it's really all about how long
you keep it on the grill for low ends
yeah because you can mess it up and then
it'll be dry the seasonings just like so
it's the way it's cooked like super
succulent
wow yeah it's pretty spicy actually
yeah if it's not spicy you're just
eating chicken
it's got a kick also I know too like if
the jerk chicken is like presented to
perfect on the plate it's not gonna slap
no it has to be like chopped up
Justine if you would do it I feel like
we need to eat up the Scotch bonnet
let's go let's go okay we're doing it
one piece okay
[Music]
they're spicy
varieties of chicken to cool it down
it's a slow build you feel it here
it is a slow build it's a good
burning it's like when you're in the gym
and you know it hurts
but you gotta keep going gotta keep
going wow but it's the flavoring of it
yeah and it's kind of pickled so the
vinegar helps cut the heat this jerk
chicken is freaking amazing amazing it's
so good okay here we go you know what
he's talking
that's when things are crazy
I'm starting to sniffle
but it's so good
it's a good burn
I'm saved wow I must say Scotch bonnet
has like a lot of good flavor though
yeah right
it's definitely like
oh one of my favorite
yeah that's the thing it spreads it
doesn't go away immediately there's a
second wave
coming mm-hmm
I'm dying happy tears mom you're on the
camera now look at the skin my mom's in
there like wait I want to eat food too
hi Mom this
is the best jerk chicken I've had in
Brooklyn to be honest are you happy
right now did it fix your craving I'm so
happy
that was happy you gotta pack some to go
home no one thousand percent
everyone's leaving with a to-go plate
like honestly thank you guys for putting
me on
oh my gosh thanks for doing this Justine
anytime you guys want me to eat some
food and try something out
just to let you know though it's gonna
be spicy
just waiting on my buddy Chef P from
ghetto gastro where are you at Chef Pee
foreign
[Music]
who got the gas
need that spice how those moves you're
doing oh I was just warming up I was
trying to make some room for some of
this spice what's up how you doing
what's up thanks for taking me around
today glad to be your tour guide oh my
God spice King spice Lord spice Lord
Brooklyn tanks West Indian Vibe a lot of
flavor I'm ready for it Scotch Bond and
scorpion peppers I can handle it a lot
of spice over here our pizza shout out
to my man Chef piggy all right shall we
let's do this get it
what's up how you doing
what is Oreo Pizza what does Oreo Pizza
means all right pizza is um a popular
strip in Trinidad and restaurants so we
just try to bring that bike in and Chef
piggy you've grown up in church today
yeah
[Music]
yeah awesome and uh what separates
Trinidadian food from the rest of the
Caribbean in uh Jamaica that they lean
more towards like barbecuing and
Grilling heavy I think in Barbados is
more fried food okay I think in Trinidad
they do a lot of really good stews the
actual Indian like talking about like
India right that that influence in
Trinidad is very uh heavily represented
in the in the food right like curries
and curries and like the chutneys and
stuff something that separates West
Indian food from Indian food is that the
fact that you can actually control the
heat right
in India they usually put all the spices
and all the Heat
and the West Indies you'll get the
flavor but then they put the pepper and
the stuff on the side so you can uh yeah
you can add it to yourself yeah all
right I'm ready to eat yes same
oh yes I have fruit salad almost yeah
yeah so exactly the spice fruit salad so
it's a mangoes pineapple cucumber I
don't like to blend it up I like you to
taste of any bite and you have garlic
and some um
scorpion pepper hot sauce it's spicy
yeah
but it's nice spice and it's salty
a little sweet freshness from the
cucumber and I love the cilantro yeah
yeah yeah yeah you do that everything
that's that's our cilantro we put that
in literally everything spicy this might
be the spiciest thing you're gonna eat
today really yes the red no the rest
you're gonna control the spice this is
just this is this is this is no
adjustments
wow so these are some Chinese style
Wings some season with like Five Spices
the Curry's three Oaks still
it's the heat Source right here yeah
that's the scorpion peppers the Scorpion
pepper sauce so talk to me about
scorpion pepper
hottest chili in the world hottest chili
in the world Carolina
for a while but you would literally eat
the Scorpio peppers like rose sauce like
you just bite it and take teaspoons
Wing cheers
you definitely taste the Chinese
influence on that too I'm just gonna be
I don't know how hot this is it's good
it's good yeah
I can't handle that right yeah of course
yeah about to find out
he eaters
it's very good that's delicious it's
spicy but like manageable I'm standing
up cause I'm about to eat some oxtail
right now and it's been years since
really it's been years since I've had oh
my God
So for anybody who hasn't seen me eat
red meat
it's about to happen right now are you
nervous it's only when I'm when I'm when
I'm eating the heat are you okay no I'm
good
and
now it's worth it yeah damn that's good
especially if it's oxtail one of my
favorite cups
delicious I also read about the
different spices that blend together
that actually Elevate the spiciness of
the pepper what I'm dealing with both
eating it together it's like it's hot
like I think
I didn't do the wing but for some reason
when I'm eating it with this it's like
really spicy you know it's spicy when
you're um when you when you start to
sniff it
when your sinuses get clear this Curry
that's the most like interesting spice
building in so many ways yeah with the
especially with the
Scorpion and peppers especially with the
scorpion pepper
oh yeah it's like a different type of
heat though it's not like spicy per se
but it's like sweaty yeah no it makes
you like leak that's why everybody in
the island is more so slow but good
though delicious if you can't handle the
heat don't come on the show
two years
all right chef next okay so we touched
Trinidad we gotta go run down on my
Beijing Bridge Run Andre AKA Shaquanda
or shaquandre they make amazing pepper
sauce with flavors inspired by Barbados
from Trinidad to Barbados who make a
quick trip don't need your passport
just need the wet
let's get it
[Music]
yellow door this is it the house of
spice
hello hello
what's up what up come on in thank you
thank you hi sweetie thanks for having
us thanks for coming over sorry I'm just
moving in so but like please welcome to
my home thank you
so Chef Pee wagwan what are we making
today we're gonna make a dish that's
owed to my Heritage and Barbados Andre's
Heritage as well and Barbados are called
fish cakes okay but we spun it at ghetto
gastro making like a little takoyaki out
of it um so we call them saltfish
takayaki inspired by like the Japanese
street food in Osaka we won on a trip
out there like the first time we saw it
we saw the resemblances and the
similarities between fritters and
takoyaki is that surely it's the same
thing it's very similar you know it's
just like the filling to us it was just
like a different filling and like a
different topic and Barbados we just
finished our fritters with like
something like a little dipping sauce on
the side what's the dipping sauce
usually the dipping sauce usually is
like the Holy Trinity the trifecta
mayonnaise ketchup and pepper sauce
pepper sauce yes chili sauce spicy Peppa
Peppa not chili okay Peppa so your
salted cod takoyaki balls I guess are
they spicy because you're slicing up
some Scotch bonnet and adding that and
will that add heat to the actual balls
yeah I'll definitely add a little add a
little heat to the balls you know we
like heat suitable
[Music]
so Andre talk to me about your hot sauce
barbanian hot sauce in general will have
turmeric mustard onions Scotch bonnet
peppers vinegar to preserve it and salt
so once you have the base you can kind
of play around so I played around with
horseradish had some apple cider vinegar
because you know I grew up in Brooklyn
so yeah hot ones they're amazing to me I
was gonna ask you what your experience
was like having your sauces on hot one
in the three spots say hello to your new
best friend Shaquanda this island style
hot sauce is made in Bed Stuy but the
Scotch bonnet and habanero driven heat
is straight out of Barbados fun fact the
name Shaquanda comes from the maker
Andre Springers drag queen Alter Ego I
put my name into a drag queen name
generator and it came back vodka Slims
like Shawn Evans is such a great host so
it's really nice to see him talk with
celebs and also the reaction of the
celebrities to the sauce right growing
up like our love language was always
cooking and like as an artist you know
like I wanted to really kind of be
authentic to what I was representing all
those like bits and pieces of my life
which was drag food and pepper sauce is
Invasion just made sense
I mean like what would you define like
Beijing cuisiness right now Beijing
Cuisine is just like layers of flavor a
lot of oral history that's been passed
down
um a lot of collaboration between
enslaved Africans and Barbados and then
also like the indigenous amerindians or
um tainino people that were there
inhabiting the islands before as well
and just like a mixture of knowledge you
know there's people from from the UK
there's people from Guyana South America
Central America Trinidad it's really the
true Melting Pot of multiple cultures a
lot of collaboration yeah we have like
the most kind of I think
deeply of mommied kind of things like we
really love like layering flavors with
onions so it's like you'll see
additional have like braised onions has
to start and then I'll have like you
know pepper sauce which is a pickled
onion and then you have dried onions and
you have you know green onions so you
have all these like expressions of a
flavor that Beijing food is really about
who wants to whisk the egg whites okay
we're just gonna fold the the stiff
whites into our batter so then this
batter is coconut milk a little bit of
egg yolk and some of that clarified
butter you can pass off and I can hop in
there too but that's just got the risk I
know I've seen her on Iron Chef
there we go
yeah starting to peek
teamwork teamwork
into our batter
green onions green onions some of the
saltfish yeah we need to make the side
sauce so yeah let's do it okay boom yeah
look all right it is literally ketchup
some of our lovely shaquandas and a
little bit of mayo
to each their own so just a little bit
of ketchup yeah I think what's the ratio
just obviously it's just how it's just
whatever you like honestly it's how you
like it oh I mean
a little
ketchup in the macaroni pie I mean for
me
more more hot sauce
looks so good I like salivating we're
gonna finish these with like a little
chalk powder and a little pick a
fermented shallot powder is a layer some
flavors some of that like some more of
that green onion sort of vibe yes this
for me is like what we use something
called Green seasoning yes exactly and
every Caribbean island has like their
version of it for us we have like a sort
of milder version that's focused more on
the onion part of it saltfish Taco Yaki
with a little bit of chive powder and
then on the side we have our Holy
Trinity sauce of mayo ketchup and our
lovely shaquandas pepper for the hot
step us and for the Beijing refers shall
we yeah let's do it yeah
[Music]
hmm
thank you matters
this style of fish cake also like light
and fluffy mm-hmm
oh yeah I love this all Cod the salt Cod
is nice in there right so good pepper
sauce perfect the Mayo need a little bit
of fat the ketchup the sweetness but
then the pepper sauce just bounces it
all out so it's so good but I need more
spicy I think
this is delicious chef
thank you Chef excellent
pleasure so good thank you guys so much
this is so fun pleasure was all out
obviously you see me I'm sweating
through my pores
Chef Peas the piece for purse
Janet it was amazing thank you thank you
oh thanks for coming over guys
some will pull it out of the collab so
these pants that I have on a ghetto
gastrocata collabs but then here this is
not a collaboration it's our spicy Maple
this is for you and it's only it only
makes sense because we use Scotch bonnet
and ghost chili and this maple syrup a
little smoke a little bitty heat amazing
Maple from ghetto crew to you thank you
[Music]
hey guys it's Esther from heat eaters
thanks for watching oh God that was
spicy
please like And subscribe and to watch
more episodes click here